PENG YING: Hi, and welcome
to Google Developers Live.
With me today is
my colleague Maru.
MARU AHUES: Hi, Peng.
PENG YING: Hi, Maru.
Now, what we're
talking about today
is the Google
Wallet Objects API.
This is another
video in our series
of videos about the
Wallet Objects API.
And today, we're going to
talk about the Wallet Objects
quick start for Ruby.
The goal of these
quick starts is
to help you hit the ground
running in your Wallet Objects
API integration.
In each of these quick
starts, we cover a few things.
We cover, hey, how do you
authorize OAuth 2.0 access
to the resources?
We cover how to insert
a Wallet Objects class.
We cover save to Wallet and
how to create a Wallet Object.
And lastly, we cover the
Wallet web service API,
which is how do you
enable a discoverable,
and how do you allow
people to sign up
for specifically
loyalty objects?
And to walk through getting
the Ruby quick start up
and running, here's Maru.
MARU AHUES: Thank you, Peng.
Now, let's go into
our documentation
to get the instructions on
how to download, install,
and configure the
Ruby quick start.
First thing is go to our
developers.google.com/commerce/wallet,
and then from there, go to the
Google Wallet Objects and click
on Quick Start
Samples and then Ruby.
Once you're there, the first
thing that I recommend you do
is watch the video
that we have on how
to set up your account,
your OAuth account,
and get your credentials.
Once you do that, then the
first thing we're going to do
is download the sample code.
To do that, we're going
to go into GitHub.
Our code is open source,
and you can download it
or you can clone it from GitHub.
To do that, the URL is
github.com/googlewallet/walletobjects-quickstart-ruby.
From here we can
just copy the URL
and clone it, or download
it to our local computer.
On my computer here, I
have it already cloned.
So this is our directory.
And these are the files that
we have for the quick start.
And take, now, a copy
of your private key--
the one that you downloaded when
you created your credentials--
and copy it into this directory.
In my case, my private key is
called wolves-privatekey.p12.
So I already created it and
copied it into this directory.
Now, let's go and
configure and make sure
that we're using the credentials
that we got into our project.
To do that, let's open the
file called wavsconstants.rv.
So I'm going to open
it here in my editor.
And I already have it here.
And from here, let's change
some of these values.
The first one is the service
account email address.
To get that, you'll need
to go into the cloud,
onto your Cloud Console here,
then click on APIs-- Registered
Apps, I'm sorry.
Service Account-project.
And from here, this
is your email address
that you'll need to use as a
service account email address.
So I'm just going to copy that
and paste it here in my file.
And also, now,
get your esure ID.
You can find that from
the merchant dashboard.
So in here, just by going
into Account Management,
we can copy paste the esure ID.
So we're copying that into here.
And now, go into the
service account private key.
For the service
account private key,
this is the name
of my private key.
But if you have
a different name,
you also need to modify that.
The application
name-- this value
doesn't need to match
any of the values
that you had when you
created your account.
So in our case, we have by
default Wallet Objects API
Demo, and you can
leave that value there.
For the origins,
this URL is the URL
where we're going to be running
the quick start locally.
So we have local host
and then port 8080.
If you're going to
be changing the port,
then you need to
modify this value.
Otherwise you can
leave it as this.
Then we have four different IDs
for the loyalty class object
ID, for the class object,
and for the offers, as well.
In this case, you can leave them
as this, or we can modify them.
If you've been running
the quick start
and you want to
create a new class,
then you'll need
to change these.
So let's say demo one
for each of these.
Once we have these, we should
be able to run the quick starts.
But before we do
that, let's make sure
that we have our
prerequisites done here.
So first, let's check
our Ruby version.
So to do that just run
version-- and I'm running 2.0.
You need to be
running at least 1.93.
So if that's good, and you
don't need to upgrade your Ruby,
then now let's
move into our gems.
For the gems, we need to
have four gems installed
for the quick start.
We need to have JSON, the
Google API client, the JWT,
and Sinatra.
So let's run-- maybe
you already have
some of these installed,
so first let's
run gem query-- local to
see which ones we have.
And in my case, I have them all.
I have Sinatra, Google
API Client, JSON, and JWT.
If you don't have one of
these, then it's very easy.
Just do gem install and
the name of the gem.
So I can do here, JSON.
So since I already installed
them, we don't need to do that.
Now, once we have that, we have
the correct version of Ruby.
We downloaded the code.
We also have all
our gems installed.
And we modified
all our parameters.
Now, all we need to
do is just run it.
To do that is very easy.
We're using Sinatra
to run the server.
And we'll call it by doing
Ruby wobs_server, which
is the name of the Ruby
script that we're running.
And then minus p
to say that we want
to run it on a specific port.
In this case, I'm
running it on port 8080.
So once we run it,
now it's telling us
that it's running on port 8080.
Everything's good.
Sinatra is running.
So now, let's go into our
browser and see how this looks.
So I have here-- we're going to
go into local host port 8080.
Once we run this, you'll see
that we have it successfully
running.
Now, what do we
have in this page?
We have two steps.
The first step, it says,
insert the class, so either
a loyalty class
or an offer class.
And then we have two
Save to Wallet buttons.
How does this work?
The first thing that
you do is that you
need to have a class
for whatever vertical
you're working
with, so let's say
that we're doing the loyalty.
You'll need to start
the class first,
and this is only done
once in the system.
You can also, of
course, update classes
after you've inserted
them, but you only
need to insert it once.
So this button will not be on
your site-- this is only here
for us to test, to show
you how to create classes
every time you modify
something on the call.
But then after, we
then started the class,
then you will have a
button, or you most probably
will have a button to
save the card or a coupon
to the user's Wallet.
So this button,
once we click it,
it will create an object
on my Google Wallet
account, where I'm
signed in, here.
And then we'll be able
to see that on the phone,
on the Google Wallet app.
So first, let me create the
class by just clicking on that.
Then, it says that it's
inserted the class--
loyalty class demo one,
which is how we named it --
and now I go into to
Save Card to Wallet,
and it saved the card already.
So now, when we go into
our Google Wallet App,
we'll see it saved.
And we'll do that
during our demo.
PENG YING: And to get
a better idea of what
classes and objects are, we also
have another Google Developers
Live video covering the
concept of what objects
they can take a look at.
MARU AHUES: Now,
let's go and look
at the web service
API integration.
We also provide a sample code
for this in our quick start.
And how this works then, from
the Google Wallet app, whenever
a user clicks on either a member
or joining the program, what
Google does is Google
will send the information
in a case on request
to your web service.
Then you will
process, on your end,
to either create a new object
or send us an existing object.
Is this is a user that already
has a loyalty card with you?
Send that information
back to us in JSON.
And then we will
display it on the phone.
So let's look at
how we can configure
that in our discoverable.
From here, from the browser
on the merchant dashboard,
if I go into
discoverables, you see here
that I'm going to edit it.
And there's a section
called merchant callback
configuration.
So in here, you need to
add the URL to the host
where you're running
your quick start sample,
and here we need it to be
running somewhere outside, not
on your local site, so you can
be reachable from our service.
And the port, and we recommend
that this is running over SSL.
For testing, you can run
it over regular HTTP.
But for when you
launch the application,
needs to be running over SSL.
Then the path to the web
service on our sample,
it's web service.
And of course, you
can change that
later to whatever makes sense
for you, your application.
Once we have this, we'll--
whenever there's a request,
then Google will send
the JSON request to you,
and you'll respond back to it.
Peng is going to do a demo on
how this works on the phone,
and then we'll go over the
code and see where all of this
is happening in the sample.
PENG YING: All right, let's
take a look at the phone.
This is the latest Wallet app.
And within this Wallet app,
we can see a few things.
This is what we call
the Here and Now page.
As you'll see, I have
one loyalty program
that I've joined.
This occurred when Maru
clicked Save This Wallet
during the demo.
So let's take a look
at that wallet program
first, or let's take a look
at loyalty object first.
It's Baconrista Rewards.
This is our demo merchant.
And within it, you
can see that hey,
I have 500 points,
that the tier I am
is gold, that it's
Maru who joints,
and some additional details
that a merchant could provide
for their loyalty objects.
Now let's take a look at
what a discoverable is,
and the web service API.
So in order to
join a new program,
let's say I'm in the
store or something,
I want to join a
loyalty program.
I hit + to find the
loyalty programs that
are available to me.
This list will also
be sorted and it'll
show programs that,
in the future,
will be relevant
to your location.
In this case, I'm going to
join our test merchant, which
is CC Baconrista Rewards.
So let's take a look
at this discoverable,
and some details about
bacon plus coffee,
your best morning every day.
And yes, I'd love to join
this one, so I'll click join.
So all of this information
that you see now
is information that's populated
from my Google Wallet slash
Google account.
And this information
can be modified
by changing some
conditions and then
discoverable of that
bar we just chose.
I accept the terms
of service, and I'll
take some promotional
emails from this merchant.
Create the account.
So this will take a few seconds
to call back to the web service
that Maru just
showed, and then it'll
to return objects to the
Google service, which will then
push the object display
back down to my device.
In this case, I have a
second card with a balance.
So in this case, maybe I
could show this balance
and use it as my stored value,
or something in the future.
So that's a quick demo.
Now here's Maru to talk
about how everything works.
MARU AHUES: From
the discoverable,
there's one thing that we need
to make sure we have set up
once we're doing
testing on our end,
is that the status of the
discoverable needs to be draft.
If it's draft, that means that
no one can see it publicly,
but we can see it
on our testing mode.
Also, you will need
to share-- If you
go to account management, you'll
need to share with the account
that you're using.
In my case here, GWalletDemo
is the email address
that Peng is using on the phone.
So as long as you get
your discoverable,
you set it on draft and you
share with the email addresses
of the accounts that you want
to share your discoverable with.
Then you can use
it on test mode.
So you won't be live to anyone
except when you're testing.
Now, let's look at
some of the code
and see how this all works out.
I'm going to open
here the editor.
And for the Ruby
sample, we have--
most of the code is included
in the wobs server RB file.
And what we're doing here is
we have-- first in this area,
we have the
authentication, and we're
doing that using OAuth 2.0.
You have your credentials,
you have your private key,
and your service
account email address.
After doing that, we
have-- let me open,
first, the index.html
so we can look at it.
When we open the sample,
the first thing you see
is the index.html page, right?
And there we have the two steps.
The first one has the buttons
to insert the loyalty class,
and the second one has the
save to wallet buttons.
So on the first one, where we
have the insert loyalty class,
we can see that these
buttons are rendered
and they're-- here,
let me ope it here--
here on the JS file that we are
including within the index.html
file, we are associating
an action to these.
When we click on the
loyalty, then we're
going to be calling
insert/loyalty.
The same for the
offer button here,
we're going to be
calling insert/offer.
then
We also have, when you're
calling the loyalty save,
or offer save--
when the page loads,
this when the page loads here,
we're calling JWT/loyalty.
And then we're also calling the
job/offer for the other button.
And what this is doing is
that it's rendering the G save
to Wallet tag on the
button, which will,
based on the JS file that we're
including on the index.html,
will render the nice
Save to Wallet button
that you see on the page.
So how does this work?
When you call the--
first let's look
at the job for the
save to Wallet button.
How this works is that you'll
go into the wobs server.
And we'll find here the path.
We're saying, if you're calling
jobs/anything, then call this.
And what this is doing is
that it's creating a job,
and it's including the
information of the object
that we're creating-- either
a loyalty object or an offer
object.
So this is what we're doing.
We're saying if it's--
the type is loyalty,
then we generate an object
and then we add the object
to the payload.
And then we encode the
JWT, and here we're
just outputting that.
So what it's doing
is that if you
see the page when we
load it, and you just
inspect the element,
you'll see that it
has the JWT on the
URL for that button.
Then, also we have the insert.
If you're going
to insert a class,
then we also have-- if you post
to insert with a type, what
we're doing in here is that
we're generating a class, also
based on the idea that we
created on the wobs constants.
And then we're
calling the API here.
We're calling our REST API to
insert the object-- the class,
in this case.
And that is returning
back an answer, and that
is displayed on the
page, on the index.html.
Then the last path that
we need to look at here
is the web service.
And this is the one
that was configured
from the discoverable.
And when you call web
service, what it's doing
is that it's checking.
It's getting-- in
our case, we are
assuming that we have success--
a successful response-- all
the time.
But you can change this value
to return a different message.
So we're saying, if
it's successful here,
we're going to create a JWT.
And we're going to send
back on the payload
that the result is approved.
And we're going to send the
loyalty object back to Google.
So how this works
here is that we're
generating an object here.
And we always generate the
same one for the sample.
But on your case, you would
say, oh it's a new member,
so we generate a
new object, and you
generate this
object on your end,
and then you send back
the information to us.
And then, of course, you
put them on the payload,
and you encode it
and send it back.
Same way that we do with the
other path, with the job path.
If their response
is not successful,
then you don't have
to send an object.
The only thing you send
back is an error message.
And the result is rejected.
In that case, then, Google
will display an error
on the Google Wallet app.
We also provide on
this sample other paths
to be able to list
classes and list objects
and get specific objects.
And those are just
examples on how
to call the RESTful
APIs using Ruby.
This concludes the Google Wallet
Objects Ruby quick start video.
We hope you found
this video helpful.
For more videos,
please visit us at
developers.google.com/livewallet.
You can also find us in
Google+ and/or Twitter.
PENG YING: Yeah,
thanks for joining us
for another week of
Google Developers Live.
BOTH: See you next time.